guten tag was darf es sein
guten tag ich hätte gerne einen
cappuccino
aber bitte ohne normale milch
was meinen sie damit
entschuldigen sie
mein deutsch ist noch nicht so gut
ich habe eine kuhmilch allergie
sie haben eine laktoseintoleranz
genau genau
wir haben auch sojamilch und mandelmilch
toll
dann gerne mit mandelmilch
so bitte schön
ihr ihren cappuccino mit mandelmilch
das macht dann fünf franken und 50
rappen
hier das stimmt so vielen dank
vielen dank
auf wiedersehen
grüezi
guten tag
was möchten sie bestellen
ich hätte gerne einen burger
[Musik]
haben sie einen ohne fleisch
sind sie vegetarierin
ja genau
wir haben einen lemberger
wir haben einen weg die bürger
der burger besteht aus kichererbsen
karotten erbsen und kartoffeln
der bürger besteht aus kichererbsen
perfekt ich nehme den veggie burger mit
pommes
welche soße wollen wieder zu
welche soße wollen sie dazu
[Musik]
ketchup
und mayonnaise ketchup
und mayonnaise sehr gerne
wir bringen ihnen den bürger an den
tisch
sehr gerne wir bringen ihnen den bürger
den tisch
der veggie burger und die pommes kosten
zusammen 15 franken
kann ich mit der karte bezahlen
natürlich
vielen dank und guten appetit
vielen dank
grüezi
guten tag
guten tag was darf ich ihnen bringen
was darf ich ihnen bringen
ich hätte gerne ein wasser
mit oder ohne kohlensäure
gerne mit kohlensäure
und dazu einen teller pasta
heute hätten wir spaghetti mit
tomatensoße im angebot
sehr gerne
darf es sonst noch etwas sein
nein das ist alles
vielen dank
abonniere die halo deutsch schule auch
auf instagram oder facebook
abonniere die halo deutsche schule auch
auf instagram oder facebook möchtest du
gratis online deutsch lernen mehr als
200 video lektionen abonniere unseren
kanal möchtest du gratis online deutsch
lernen mehr als 200 video lektionen
abonniere unseren kanal